The betrayal of the partner is forbidden in almost all cultures but somehow adds flavor ...
For the plot of films and the inspiration for countless songs about the wound of the heart, but why ...
People basically betray, can you explain it scientifically?
Only 3% of mammals are single-husband, meaning they live throughout their lives with one partner
Man is classified into this category, from an evolutionary perspective this creates ...
An advantage where one partner protects the young and the other looking for food
It provides resources. But in some way, associating with an additional partner is common human behavior ...
so far.
Genetic encoding of dopamine receptors plays a key role in infidelity in men and women
Sometimes called "happiness hormone" and excreted after fun activities such as ...
Training, eating and orgasm, a study showed that 50% of people who carry ...
The long allele of this gene has betrayed their partners compared with 22% of people ...
Who carry the short allele. Long-elongated carriers also have a tendency to ...
To be aggressive and subject to addiction behaviors such as alcoholism, perhaps the phrase ...
"Who once betrayed, betrayed a thousand times" may actually have a basis.
The levels of vasopressin have a role in it also similar to the hormone oxytocin which sometimes ...
Called "Hormone Hormone", the hormone Vasopressin can affect the trust, empathy and social cohesion
In fact, vasopressin is injected into the reward system for multi-pair mountain field mice ...
Increases the likelihood of becoming a single pair. People with autism have low levels of vasopressin
Affecting their ability to understand social signals, and in 2014 a study was conducted ...
More than 7,000 Finnish twins have shown that women who are infected have a diversity in the gene that cures ...
Vasophosphrine receptors, further suggested that low levels of phosphosperin have the effect of ...
On treason.
Money may also be an important factor. Men who earn more than their peers are much more ...
They are more likely to be betrayed, but they are also more likely to betray their wives if ...
They were fathers of the house, only when they had equal earning opportunities ...
The rates of treason in both are significantly reduced.
Of course, many other life factors may lead to betrayal such as unresolved emotional problems
Previous relationships and excessive drinking, and unfortunately the homosexual relationships ...
Not sufficiently studied to get clear insights and highlight ...
Scientific research continues to exclude certain minority groups.
In both cases, treason is clearly based on biology and heredity for some of us although we ...
Single - parent types.
: Translation Yassir Asa'ad
https://www.facebook.com/yassir.asaad98
Subscribe to the channel for more scientific videos!